the techie guy hacked a random security
camera with a smart bulb from the
garbage to make that experiment he needs
to find their IP address first he hacked
the Wi-Fi thanks to credentials that
were stored in a discarded smart bulb
that's why even if you have a strong
password if you're throwing away a smart
bulb you're throwing away all the
information it has so to find the camera
system itself he used nmap command which
will map out their entire network show
any open ports and identify any devices
that he can hack and done after entering
the IP address of the camera in the web
he found the type of the system they
have articles also said that there could
be no password for this type of camera
let's see if this is true two hours
later hi oh yeah he's in they might be
lucky it's just an experiment it's
really shocking but that's how easy it
is be careful and follow samsa to
protect yourself